you know a lot about Keanu and you know
what pretty clear that Ianno is having a
moment et has been there for everything
of cool Keanu what I love movies there's
been Ted built Ted
gosh I love movies there is a bomb on
this bus I love watching them and I love
making them this week piano has become a
viral sensation thanks to his passionate
way with words minds were blown and
respect was given when fans discovered
he never touches women during photo ops
hypnotism lady knew he was just about
the coolest guy in the room during our
nearly 35 years with the star Oh
starting in the 80s when he turns
playing Ted into an excellent spiritual
adventure I kind of had him in my body
for a long time after and just in my
spirit he was there a lot it's fun Ted
Ted I'm feeling blue where are you dude
don't be down it's all okay
in the 90s County starred in his first
action film with 1991 Point Break
surfing
every day ichi was on the Hawaii set and
we just dare you not to hang on every
word osteon who describes filming in the
ocean yeah I'm just trying to play the
part know the ocean in the world and and
giving stuff back to the ocean because
you're surfing it about the mindset of
being a true surfer this mean pretty
much says it all
Keanu oh just existing and the entire
Internet what makes him the best pretty
much everything the major love of her
Keanu oh we've got even more because
we're gonna be with them tonight at the
Toy Story 4 premiere and Hollywood
[Applause]
[Music]